Olha essa Q. Será que uma colher de
azeite por dia pode realmente proteger o
seu cérebro da demência? Pois é, parece
bom demais para ser verdade, mas veja só
o que a ciência tá mostrando. Um estudo
gigante de Harvard, publicado em 2024
acompanhou mais de 92.000 pessoas por
quase 30 anos. E o resultado foi
impressionante. Quem consumia azeite
regularmente teve até 28% menos risco de
morrer por causas relacionadas à
demência. E olha, não precisa ser muito
não. Meia colher de sopa por dia já foi
suficiente para mostrar esse benefício.
Mas por que que o azeite faz isso? Ele é
rico em polifenóis, vitamina E,
compostos que protegem as células do
cérebro e os vasos sanguíneos contra
inflamação e oxidação. É como se você
estivesse colocando um escudo protetor
no seu cérebro todos os dias. Claro,
estamos falando de azeite extra virgem
de verdade, não aqueles óleos compostos
que vendem por aí como se fossem azeite.